I appreciate the movie eros Pacific
DreamWorks logo but hue is dead does
this mean the normal dreamworks fishing
kid on the moon is also dead and a ghost
long ago mary shit what had brought
color and joy could also bring darkness
and destruction this movie suggests
gunpowder was invented in the pursuit of
pure joy also huge important
expositional back story told quickly via
narration in flashbacks cliche what had
brought color and joy could also bring
darkness and destruction
that's true but really only when the
thing bringing color and joy is also
made of explosives I'd be really
impressed if you'd with an eyes today a
ring bow or metal flowers he would be
defeated by a warrior of black and white
I'm guessing in Kung Fu Panda 3 PO will
fulfill some other prophecy making him
the Dexter fulfilling Chinese prophecies
the young Lord set out to change his
fate but what he did next only sealed it
that's the lesson Shifu learned in the
first movie in 2008 and what Oedipus
learned in the 5th century BC this
lesson is a very old storytelling device
is what I'm saying
horrific panda genocide is firmly
implied but completely glossed over
according to this story a crazy son who
mastered the dark arts of gunpowder and
killed all the pandas will simply turn
around and leave when his happy
fireworks joyjoy parents banished him
nor is he hiding out Mount Doom if
America still had a strong steel
industry movies wouldn't be so quick to
characterize factories as places of evil
and then did you Ivan warrior join the
Furious Five if PO joined the Furious
Five what does that make them now the
ridiculous 6 these movies are obsessed
with the word awesome Plus 10 sins for
never cracking open a thesaurus no one
else is as impressed as I am with Poe's
ability to speak with large quantities
of food in his mouth you'll save those
for me right I sure as hell hope so you
shall basically all of them in his mouth
does inner peace also give you the
ability to alter the properties of space
and time if not then what kung fu power
is allowing him to operate from one
location to another some choose to
meditate for 50 years in a cave just
like this
without the slightest taste of food or
one those are the masters who died both
the day you were chosen as Dragon
Warrior was the worst day of my life
Shifu really knows how to cut deep when
we think of all the things that happened
to Shifu his adopted son that he trained
to be the Dragon Warrior wasn't the
Dragon Warrior and he went crazy and
tried to kill everyone and then he came
back and tried to kill him also his
master being carried away by peach tree
leaves and so on saying this is pretty
low
bandits approaching musicians village a
whole village of musicians those bandits
are cos still much more than empty pizza
boxes and some rolling papers
cranes ability to fly even when he is
carrying an inconceivable amount of
weight is soaping impressive I have
trouble believing it is this rabbit
warning every one of the attackers
before they arrived was he able to see
them through the dense fog and what I
can only imagine is a Peter Pan style
flying pirate ship if not the timing of
all this seems off I hope this is the
same rabbit from the first scene of the
last movie that was high as because he
looks a heck of a lot better here but it
still looks eyes get all the metal you
kid fine
who's he talking to he's definitely not
within earshot of any of us hyena bandit
friends and did they not already know
what the plan was before conducting this
mission I feel like this guy slash dog
just like to hear himself talk
rob the metal is there anyone in their
group confused about what they're trying
to accomplish why did they keep
repeating what they should all know
they're here to do good work Poe warn
them that you're coming you're doing a
lot of standing around for a group of
dogs that just need some metal to finish
their fleet of cannons Shen would be
pissed if he found out they were hanging
around picking fights when they could
easily head back with the metal the one
image opens up a cavalcade of very
traumatic memories cliche also posed
flashback is still inexplicably
two-dimensional so earlier when he said
get all the metal you can find he forgot
to also say so we can throw most of it
off this cliff thank you for coming to
Dragon Gorion noodles and tofu stage
parents he once waited on awesome yeah I
have this game to prove it wasn't this
the dick paid from the last movie that
made fun of Poe now he's a smug dick Pig
well you see son baby Keys come from a
little egg his ping really trying to
tell PO he was a goose besides him being
obviously a panda all the other animals
have referred to him as Panda countless
times
deny almost run deep for ping you might
have been kind of adopt
listen up adoptive parents waiting this
long to tell your child they're adopted
is not cool then again we also need to
send PO for somehow believing he could
look like he does and be called panda
but still be descended from skinny Birds
pings flashbacks are not to dementia
so this problem is clearly isolated to
Pope also adoption backstory no one
cares about Oh is the only mammal who
was raised without the need for milk
no wonder he's the dragon warrior this
is the only time in recorded history a
conspicuous trail of food has not ended
at a box propped up on a stick why is he
just lately chewing on that dumpling
instead of eating it whole like the
other ones he just had maybes full but
PO is never full never being full must
be a skill he learns later in life
feeding and bathing a creature in the
same container who tried to put some
pants on those aren't even goose pants
that's just a small blanket but his
pings plan here maybe he's just telling
PO about the pants but remembering a
time when he tried to wipe his ass and
then I made a decision that would change
my life forever to make my soup without
radishes I don't think that was a
decision as much as it was poet all the
radishes but if he was being truthful we
wouldn't have this forced unapologetic
misdirection one dumpling please Dragon
Warrior sighs I just have so many
questions
why didn't I like pants because ping
didn't know the difference between pants
and small blankets did Lord Shen just
use the force gently waving your wing in
someone's general direction doesn't seem
very comfy to me maybe the guards are
those easily startled narcoleptic goats
yes did you see the peacock on the front
door I guess you can get away with a
statement when there is only one living
peacock in this universe it seems your
fortune-telling skills are not as good
as you thought ah the villain with an
upper-class English accent cliche
arguably the best of all accent cliches
it's no southern accent equals stupid
but it's up there did this Rhino carve
those patterns onto his horn or is that
just how they're built in this world I
want to believe he carved it himself
because that is hard core shell off
speaking of show-offs he would have been
able to use this cannon a lot sooner if
he didn't bother to have it carved in
the shape of a dragon for a flightless
bird Chan is frightfully Flavel an
additional sin for making me
accidentally make up a word and coming
up with a tongue twister some situations
require a little less kung-fu and a
little more getting out of the way son
of legendary flying right now did anyone
else just imagine a rhino with wings
flying through the air dipping in and
out of the clouds having the time of his
life cuz I sure did I mean how can kung
fu stop something that stops kung fu'
movie unintentionally tries to break
your brain how did ping know to pack him
a travel pack did he know they were
going to fight Shen before they did are
all the bird species secretly evil and
subservient to Lord Shen and Kung Fu
Panda 3 is going to be interesting also
pose dad vastly underestimates how much
PO eats somehow and that's me giving you
a piggyback ride this is a painting did
PO have to sit on pings back causing him
excruciating
well someone painted this don't worry
mr. ping he'll be back before you can
say noodles that is decidedly false
he'd probably would be less tired if he
wasn't carrying that travel pack no one
else has a trouble back boob all the
animators in this film got too artsy
again what is it about kung fu that
makes you no longer need mattresses or
pillows they should call it chiropractic
Phu PO hasn't eaten all these potatoes
yet where did this boat come from this
is the first time they're actually using
some mode of transportation instead of
just leaping incredible distances they
probably had the boat all along and
monkey remember that they had the boat
and said remember how we're always just
jumping everywhere why don't we use that
boat that we have on the outskirts of
town and everyone else was like oh yeah
that boat we don't see this because
Jackie Chan isn't allowed to talk in
this movie either how did he only wake
up tigress the rest of the five are
pretty heavy sleepers I used to punch
the Ironwood trees by the Palast train
now I feel nothing which would also
explain why she has such giant hands oh
why are you really out here besides the
fact that he's definitely the Dragon
Warrior and it's his job you mean your
dad the goose that must have been quite
a shock humbled me too the jerk joke for
the first movie but it bears repeating
not omae's the Mantis has made it this
long without getting squashed if I felt
something walk all over me like that I
would involuntary swat at it even if it
was one of my friends Oh having daddy
issues what is it with the characters in
this movie being arbitrarily and
unnecessarily cruel I get the symbolism
here and how this is a slap in the face
to his father and all but now he has
nowhere to sit he should have at least
brought his own throne and they replaced
the chair with the cannon not only does
Shin no longer have a place to sit be as
a giant cannon in his throne room that
he will eventually have to move again
cuz that's a cannon and it does no good
just sitting in the middle of a room
thirty years I've waited for this moment
according to the Internet peacocks only
live for about 15 years
but if he's partially made of metal I'm
willing hey this movie is making me
learn again damn you Kung Fu Panda -
you're just saying what's happening
right now
he's not talking to me is he a peacock
is defeated by a warrior of black and
white did no one during the development
of this movie tell them what en and yang
actually mean it's about how opposite or
contrary forces are actually
complementary which doesn't seem to have
anything to do with the Panda defeating
a peacock in battle it was just a
recognizable Chinese symbol that they
just threw in Bart panda even now that
he's a kung-fu master he still has some
major issues with self control even PO
causing all this commotion the Wolves
still didn't notice the pose walking
around the city streets obvious pac-man
reference is obvious and not enough to
save this movie they are surrounded by
wolves yet they are still able to get
out from under the costume and into the
barrels with
anyone seeing them maybe they've all
mastered that operating skill that Shifu
showed off earlier in this movie they
gave the Wolves no time to get away
there's no way they could have been far
enough away from them to not hear them
get up start walking and po gets stuck
and fall down making even more noise
also there was a conveniently sized
bucket for mantis look young man jail
and they conveniently happened upon the
jail they were looking for I'll give you
a signal okay
you mean like crane does yeah excuse me
when have I ever made that noise I hate
it when the characters in the movie in
the movie makes me feel so unnecessary
then the weapon would kill everyone
movie Burroughs mysterious super weapon
of death from all the movies kung fu is
dead hey hey my my kungfu can never die
monkey monkey continuing to be pointless
he is like the ringo star of the Furious
Five how are the Furious Five a group
that frequently runs and leaps
impossibly not able to quickly catch up
with this rickshaw driven by a short
legged goat those rata children not
scared out of their minds flying up to
the street on a strange panda which to
them is an animal they've never seen
before did their parents not teach them
about stranger danger movie steals the
mind car scene from Indiana Jones and
the deathly hallows I mean Harry Potter
and the Temple of Doom I mean even what
I mean it feels like I'm fighting a big
old fluffy cloud okay it's official this
guy totally has a panda fetish these
animals have very little regard for
King's Landing
eight-point acupressure cuffs just like
I want you to hide long a blink and
you'll miss a call back to the previous
film sin of why bother with this 40
minutes in bad guy is practicing his
meet the captured good guy greeting as
though he's a good guy when he's
actually a bad guy whose soldiers
captured the good guy guy did they set
up a memorial for the guy that they very
intentionally killed I mean that's nice
but kind of odd to see mournful for
someone they murdered the cannon that
was so heavy the two giant gorillas
didn't want to move it two inches to the
left
flies up into the air with little effort
after Tigris jumps on the front of it
and then mattis who is light as a sheet
of paper is able to kick it through the
floor with vigor okay the Sun symbol and
the pattern on Chen's feathers looked
kind of the same but this seems a lot
harder than just using all of Shin to
match up with his flashback cuz he was
actually there since peacocks are mostly
flightless birds I can only assume that
he isn't actually flying he's falling
with style
how many freaking stories is this pagoda
I guess ropeburn doesn't affect pandas
why going how can he see where they are
aren't they on the backside of a
building that he is pretty far away from
because it's the middle of the year so
you'd only get like a half of the year
of the peacock
characters from within the movie are
continuing to sin from the inside they
all know Poe and the Furious Five er
stole
why so why are they calling all the
wolves leading our heroes to roam the
city freely that makes no sense
why is mantis suddenly so much bigger is
this some sort of prospective thing that
wasn't animated well where did mantis
accidentally drinks some drink me liquid
from Alice in Wonderland they will keep
you far from danger you're not keeping
anyone from anything they have locked
themselves in a jail cell even though
he's the Dragon Warrior the five-digit
because they didn't see the first movie
apparently when old China is my reward
but now you won't know where he is
because he just destroyed his map she
said the safe free she's no use to me it
feels weird dissing this cuz it almost
sounds like a request but shouldn't he
just kill her this peacock loves murder
I can't feel my face but I love it hey
why even fake say hey that was a real
gamble for PO to almost make himself
known when none of that interaction was
necessary in the first place
I'm glad he's doing all this rolling cuz
if he wasn't he would just be walking
which would be about the same and
probably take less time
why does PO keep ending up with a walk
on his head they're doing it at a
frequency that makes it seem significant
but all it has accomplished is
additional silliness sudden cannon hits
Po and I'm instantly reminded of Homer
Simpson's stint with the travelling
concert and the cannon gag and I'm
instantly no longer worried about PO
just like Yoda in the prequels Master
Shifu is relegated to reaction shots of
him feeling something wrong with the
force I mean come foo in general did po
just go from experiencing his memories
in first person to third person i
foretold that someone would stand in his
way
a panda PO is basically Harry Potter
first of all posed panadol survives the
fire second of all would a panda really
have a stuffed animal of a panda if I
grew up with a stuffed doll of a white
dude I'd probably have trouble sleeping
at night po finally remembers long
buried memories because the plot needs
him to pose version of inner peace is
remembering how his parents died that's
stopped I guess inner peace is what
allows your flashbacks to look like
reality instead of two-dimensional
drawings mom panda puts PO on a
vegetable cart so he can be saved even
if she cannot and hello I sense some
serious Moses overtones here someone
very dedicated to his job found this box
of vegetables amongst a war zone filled
with corpses and still made the delivery
to the noodle shop now that's a hero
movie uses over a full minute of the
previous movies footage in an emotional
montage party foul
I am po and I'm gonna need a hat
he means a walk everyone seems to be
living their lives pretty normally and
are surprised when they see this weapon
float by did none of these animals see
or hear the tallest building in their
city fall to the ground that happened
hours ago and everyone seems pretty
blas about it I always thought I'd meet
a nice girl and settle down
and she'd eat my head n c---seventeen
dialogue somehow makes it into a kids
movie just to be clear Shen didn't
really weaponize fireworks so much as he
just decided to point them at people and
things Paul okay it's bad enough all
these good guys notice this really
distant PO but then to say it out loud
for shendi here are you looking hi
tigress Jesus ever hear a stealth Shen
probably should have designed a weapon
that would be a little easier to
maneuver the general rule the thwart all
of Chen's weapons is don't be directly
in front of it and if you are moved
slightly Master Shifu ex machina in a
piece how convenient that this is the
lesson he just learned the cannon ball
looks like the center of a plasma globe
and that's why gunpowder was outlawed
forever wait what scar is heal no they
don't
wounds heal okay if the characters in
the movie can hear me please stop
sending each other I'm going to run out
of things to say
were those shins I won the battle
fireworks that just happen to go off
anyway
I did this community have fireworks
planned for when the battle was over
it's good that they want under the
fireworks would have been super
inappropriate what do you mean he's not
here
I remember this woman I used to have
interactions with her when I worked
retail she hasn't changed a bit looks
and sounds just the same my son is alive
how did he find that out sitting in the
hut maybe he was looking at his iPad and
got a CNN news alert dragon word defeats
evil Lord Chen storming ox announces on
Twitter the entire panda colony decided
to look up at Poe's biological father at
the same time with no provocation who
cares this is all just a setup to
complete the trilogy because they knew
the sequel was going to make Bank
you
hush now my baby don't Jack Jack there's
a boat are using Vanessa's defense
against MEAC I thought it fitting
considering the rocky tre
what's in the box Shen you want to see
ah what's in a bar hole in the wall all
of them who you choose to be
who are you Panda